hi everybody  welcome to the set of Jungle Cruise I'm  so excited to welcome you to this  incredible movie as you can see we have  a beautiful puff lit behind us  usually to show people that the  beautiful path and then you have the  beautiful co-star Wow no I think this  was just sorry I just I'm here no no I  just this was just supposed to be you  were telling me hey let's be like  Humphrey Bogart and I'm Kathleen Hepburn  Kathleen or is it Kathryn it's what do  you research okay  Michael Douglas Kathleen Turner that's  it that's right Fred Astaire Ginger  Rogers they were never in the jungle so  it's a love story it is a love story yes  welcome to Jungle Cruise it's gonna be  great the adventure of a lifetime  wait I'm sorry I'm sorry wait come back  one second  come on back there you go just kidding  welcome for the adventure of a lifetime  no no I did  [Music]